[Music]
[Laughter]
this show is brought to you by Kasia as
you know cash up is the simplest way to
send to send and save money and now it's
the simplest way to try and grow your
money introducing cash app investing
unlike investing tools that only let you
buy entire shares of stock cash app lets
you instantly invest as little or as
much as you want this way when your
favorite company stock is just a little
too expensive you can still own a piece
with as little as $1 and because cash up
is directly connected to your bank
account there are no four to five day
waiting periods for inbound transfer so
you can start investing today brokerage
services are provided by cash app
investing a subsidiary of square and
member s IPC and as always when you sign
up for cash app and use the promo code
Congrats not only will you instantly
receive ten dollars but cash up will
also now donate ten dollars to The
Trevor Project an amazing organization
that provides crisis intervention and
suicide prevention services to LGBTQ
youth across America download cash app
from the App Store or Google Play Store
today 149 of congratulations we have one
episode left until ever until episode
150 and you know what that means
[ __ ] nothing dude we do what we want
here we don't give a [ __ ] we do what the
[ __ ] we want maybe 150 is gonna be good
maybe it's not gonna be good maybe it
[ __ ] I look here's what I want to
actually say before I even get into what
the [ __ ] going on I do this [ __ ] for
me okay
it's for me I saw it sometimes I see his
podcast is funnier than a stand-up and
his stand-up is funny in this podcast I
blocked those people I don't give a [ __ ]
I'm not doing it for you okay and
because of that let me know let me even
go
even 1% I'm not doing it for you you
know how much I'm doing it for you zilch
okay you know what that means because
I'm doing it for me
hun it do you know what it means because
I'm doing it for me Han it do you know
what that means that I'm not doing it
1% for you that it's for you that's what
that means the fact that I'm relaxed I'm
relaxed like picture me just like
chillin on a [ __ ] lounge chair I have
a mai tai own even drink but I have a
mai tai and have a little bit of [ __ ]
turkey sausage and I'm just eating it
off a plate and it's [ __ ] beautiful
it's beautiful out it's like 75 degrees
80 degrees and I'm in a bathing suit and
it's high cuz that's what's in fashion
and I'm just eating sausage and drinking
a [ __ ] americano but I have a mai tai
just in case I want start drinking today
yeah is there me okay uh and I'm just
chilling dude that's that's the me
that's the me you're gonna get I'm
relaxed dude and I'm doing me
you know [ __ ] that Luke Bryant guy
who is just like I'm doing my thang he
made a song called doing my thang yeah
sir regular he did that that's my
[ __ ] theme song now ever heard the
song once no have I probably heard it
once and a [ __ ] Macy's commercial yeah
sometime yeah but dude I'm relaxed and
the best me is relaxed baby and if you
tell me if you rank my [ __ ] online it
get blocked dude whether you follow me
or not dude you could say hey your
standard spread in your Park is your
Park is better if you put standup
I go like this check profile block cuz
why the [ __ ] don't want you ranking me
why do I want you rank in my [ __ ] no
that's it I created this channel to do
what I want do you know why I'm a
[ __ ] baby dude I'm a baby a [ __ ]
baby and babies do what they want you
gotta get
that [ __ ] point in your life dude I
understand everyone's got jobs I
understand that [ __ ] yeah sure you
know sometimes your mom gets cancer
whatever the [ __ ] I get it but you got
to still get to the point where you kind
of feel like you're doing what you want
do it it's the matrix man it's neo when
he stops all the bullets and he's a
crime and he just looks at him and [ __ ]
his head and the bullets fall down dude
you got to get to the point where you
feel like you're on a [ __ ] lounge
chair chillin with a mai tai and iced
americano
and then also some turkey sausage if
that's what you care about
it's all about feeling man you know like
you could be in prison dude you could be
in prison for [ __ ] eight years and
you're on you're one dude guess what you
still have you can still think of
titties gods can't stop you from
squirting it's all how you feel life can
rip in [ __ ] eight by eight life can
rip all clinked up cuz the guards can't
stop you from squirting guard I'm
squirting god damn it they don't go
freeze they don't do that they say off
to the hole fine put me in the hole
still squirting how are you gonna stop
me from thinking two titties dude
straight up man
how you gonna do it it's like this it's
like this song this is the song I think
of when I [ __ ] think about how you
can't this is the song dude when when I
[ __ ] when this song came out bro I
can't play a lot of it you can't stop me
from thinking about titties a little oh
yo you do too oh yeah you can't tell me
nothing yeah guards can't stop me from
squirting your little oh you do little
ooh
[Laughter]
you bud Liotta LaHood its curtain dude
[ __ ] guards come get me guards dude
come get me guards [ __ ] yeah I love that
[ __ ] I don't you know what and I'm
already sweating so here's the deal man
it's been [ __ ] six minutes and 42
seconds and I'm squirt I'm sweatin I'm
squirting out the [ __ ] underarms man
how about my opener goes on stage with
[ __ ] uh he goes on stage open for me
and sometimes he wears gray shirts bro
you can't do that if you're shaped like
a [ __ ] pair that it hasn't come off
the tree yet you know I'm talking about
do it you're gonna get [ __ ] dark
circles under your [ __ ] armpits and
under your teddies now am I talking
about titties too much in this episode
yes
does it matter no dude because I'm gonna
[ __ ] lounge chair chillin with a mai
tai if I want it and an iced americano
and turkey sausage horse died ever bro
worst diet of all time just [ __ ] in
concept either constipated or [ __ ]
so hard dude
one time I knew a [ __ ] girl and she
ate so many prunes and then she was on
the beach in the Bahamas and she got off
of her lounge chair and she'd even
realize that she [ __ ] all over it
you understand that that's the [ __ ]
place I'm trying to be ate too many
prunes and nut [ __ ] all over the lounge
chair down low yep doodle Woodley oddly
uh whoa you can't tell my ass nothin
dude [ __ ] it
that's really what's up dude that's
really what's up anyway dude anyway I
got I got off I you know it was like I
haven't been I was I was on the road so
now I'm just [ __ ] chillin and so I got
off to a hot and we have you know we got
off hot and it's fine and the frequently
visited [ __ ] sites on my on my
[ __ ] desktop am I am i Safari are
YouTube my own website Saiga testicle
the Twitter Help Center for some [ __ ]
and reason and pornhub even though I
haven't [ __ ] watched porn hub in so
long
did I sort of God pornhub makes themself
go on the thing I maybe watch [ __ ] to
porns this year um anyway so what was I
gonna do oh look at look up the shits
I'm really with the shits today dude I'm
really with the shits man tour Peoria
I'm coming for some reason Chicago
Illinois come spend New Year's Eve with
me dude
it'll be fun man I do I you know I have
two shows on New Year's Eve and one
before that or something like that can't
remember I have [ __ ] three shows I
think in in Chicago Illinois
you know why dude whatever they [ __ ]
love your boy in Chicago what's that
[ __ ] I got to take this bar oh I'm so
[ __ ] hot man
I know I turn the fan on but still it's
[ __ ] hot I got the air on I got the
fan on the Fianna underneath he's got a
goat underneath dude people look at me
they go are they're actually go flakes
on it now it's just the [ __ ] fabric
but I'll tell you dude well as I say in
Peoria Chicago Illinois but they [ __ ]
but it's whatever dude but what was I
was trying to say is about the I have a
lot of gray in my beard man and it's not
going away it keeps coming I looked at
Will Sasso the other day doesn't even
have that much he's like [ __ ] seven
years older than me doesn't have as much
gray as I do
and Bryan Callen of course [ __ ] makes
it you know he puts that [ __ ] in it that
you see the guys you see in CVS or shop
right where the hell you are and you see
the guys on the on the those [ __ ]
bitch-ass dudes that model for the just
for men and they're just like this I
want to model for just for men do it and
a but still have a little bit of gray in
my beard and be on the [ __ ] cover cuz
everybody's so goddamn handsome on that
[ __ ] and me and then and then you walk
by and then me and you see me on the
last one like this and you're like but
he's still gray a little bit and what
does that face he's making and then you
just [ __ ]
and then you and then you're just like
and then you're just like oh I think I
get what's going on he's making his face
ugly cuz he wanna l'eau de l'eau de
l'eau he looks like a bird and he also
looks like mr. burns a little bit um
anyway dude uh yeah so I was like
[ __ ] watching the old clips of me
because I'm very [ __ ] egotistical
and I was watching old clips of me and I
saw how I had [ __ ] it just a
straight-up magicians quaff and like
super like like fine hair like like a
like a peach fuzz but a little bit but
like burnt peach fuzz on my [ __ ] face
and it looked really good and I was even
younger than I am now if you can believe
that even though I'm the youngest guy
you've already [ __ ] you've ever seen
alright and I was like Jesus Christ man
I look better now okay I look better now
unless it's the morning in the morning I
look [ __ ] bad and gray yeah okay
but bro I was looking at the clips and I
was like [ __ ] what happened to that
boy what happened to that boy what
happened to that boy that's what I was
thinking dude do you believe that what
for the life of me I could not
understand why anybody would ever listen
his partners but it's not NPR so yo I
was thinking about also being it like a
chick if you were a chick like I just
wiped my nose with my [ __ ] shirt like
that and I know I'm not even 40 but you
boys got some miles on him but like a
girl can't do that I did Whitney
Cummings podcast she couldn't [ __ ] him
wipe her nose with her shirt people like
make a Jif of it bro me your boy make a
Jif of it what the [ __ ]
anyway I'm going to Peoria I'm going to
Chicago Illinois I was in Houston dude
your boy had a day man I think I'm a
rapper dude like straight up I was
walking through the airport in Houston I
had just landed I heard a Chris and I
looked around and dude it's [ __ ]
legend DJ premier Oh bro you know me
I've been knowing you since high school
now granted we text and we [ __ ]
Instagram but bro he's like
yo Chris and a look he goes premiere and
I was like I know and I was like oh man
it's so [ __ ] nice to meet you dude I
[ __ ] love you man I love your [ __ ]
I've been a fan for so long and he was
like oh man you know telling me all the
[ __ ] telling me what the hell he's been
working on telling me well he's got free
you come in bro
the [ __ ] he's got coming I can't I can't
he goes like this Shh
if you leave if it gets lead I know it's
you dude I'm in the hip-hop game now I
know secrets
I know I know hip-hop secrets I would
never tell them okay I'm premieres boy
Jenna Sammy he trusts me so when you're
asking yourself we see old clips and say
what happened to that boy you look at me
now he's oh that's what happen to that
boy he's very trustworthy so so I
[ __ ] he told me what's going on and
we talked about a little bit and he made
a video put it on his Instagram I
[ __ ] reposted it and then he reposted
mine bro it kept going it was like
Inception I was like how many times do
we reposed the thing got so small on the
two-story post you know people keep
proposing to keep proposed to keeper
horses like those Russian dolls
hey Russians those aren't good anymore
okay
you know those [ __ ] Russian dolls
that keep coming out of each other those
were cool in the 1600s it's 2019 I get
that it's a [ __ ] fixture lose it you
know those are firewood you know why
there's iPads Russian dolls dude anyway
so anyway I [ __ ] I met DJ premier it
was so cool he was leaving Houston and I
forgot he was from Houston because I
think of him as a New York guy my
brothers from h-town and then [ __ ]
bun be texted me told me yeah I'm coming
to your show and I was like hell yeah I
got him tickets you know and then bun be
got there and he was like I'm here bro
and then I was like come on back came
back and [ __ ] we chilled for a little
bit so what my point is I hung out with
DJ premier and also bun be in one day
I'm a rapper they probably should put me
in one of those [ __ ] miniseries
documentaries and that Netflix do be
like yeah well you know when I was in
Houston one day I hung out premiere and
also Bambi and that's just like how the
hip hop hip hop game was back in 2019
Wow imagine if it cut to me on that and
I said that and then they'd be like is
that the [ __ ] guy from that show
anyway dude but it's you know [ __ ]
bun b and DZ over me or to my favorites
and and that's what's up all i also
added another show in a really ontario
wherever the [ __ ] that is even though
it's a made-up place for sure that would
be a place in like it's like they were
referred to in Narnia in the movie
Narnia movies and they'd be like it's
because we're all trying to get to
earlier and they'd be like don't speak
of that place and then at the end you go
there and it's realize it wasn't what
you thought it was the whole time and
but it's beautiful anyway we shouldn't
play an Irvine I'd even know that and
the Pasadena ice house Jesus Christ what
happened to that boy anyway I watch the
Irishman and people were talking about
how fantastic it is and yeah I mean
Scorsese really can make a [ __ ] movie
huh that's what you realize when you
watch that movie you'd be like all
courses you could really make a [ __ ]
movie huh
this guy just killed it like the [ __ ]
sequences and [ __ ] the sequences and the
scenes the scenes just standing alone
some of these seams just went like Al
Pacino and Robert De Niro talking and
you're like goddamn well now but you
know it's just like oh yeah and you're
just like you know he's like oh that's
the [ __ ] scenes and then Pesci is
just like yeah DeNooyer just
oh yeah that's the scene in the Irishman
that's my favorite scene in the Irishman
but dude the [ __ ] [ __ ] is so and then
the other guy the British dude that's in
it that plays the [ __ ] the other guy
the guy from what's that [ __ ] house
of cards but in that 1400s the HBO show
Matt says it's his favorite show ever
Boardwalk Empire house of cards in the
1400 s whatever the [ __ ] that move show
us that's what I call that show and and
he's just like and I'm like this guy's
British how's it gonna pull off a
[ __ ] mobster and he just comes in
he's like you just don't understand and
on my god dammit British guys British
actors could [ __ ] play a white
British guy could play an Asian and just
be Asian and and you'd be like no I
won't make up hold on they'd make up
I've got acting I've got acting in me
corner or donate my cup I've got acting
in me corner and he'd be like whoa okay
and he would come on this on the set he
would just be like Gordon Jupiter video
is it on yeah oh god no you got nuts
order and they'd be like Jesus Christ
maybe I cut maybe like oh wow that was a
good one I can go another take of
something like that okay let's get
touch-ups
Waldo need a touch-up I've got Achtung
in me corner and action cut always crap
service I need I need some almonds I
need some almonds and some peanut butter
anyway watch the [ __ ] Irishman and
you know the way it starts is a Scorsese
alright it's like you know when we
started like one of those [ __ ] things
you know you remember Goodfellas where
he was just like as far back as I can
remember I always wanted to be a
gangster man my lamb you know
yeah whatever the [ __ ] it was and then
in this one it's just like hey you know
when we first started and it just that's
how I [ __ ]
De Niro and then but uh yeah I watched
it and wrote my buddy Sebastian is in it
okay
this Sebastian Maniscalco bro I knew he
was in it okay but when you see him in
it you're like oh dude my friends in a
[ __ ] nut Martin Scorsese movie and
he's [ __ ] dude got sunglasses and
he's just walking around
dude he's acting with veneer oh oh man
dude it's like a trip he's acting
without Pacino and he's doing his
sebastian [ __ ] al pacino's like [ __ ]
oh yeah and Sebastian's like what it's
[ __ ] awesome dude anyway I was
watching the Irishman and I was thinking
about how Anna Paquin was in it and I
was like man she's kind of killing it in
my head I was like man she's killing it
and she doesn't even really have lines
you know and I was like that's just to
goes to show you is you don't need lines
to be a good actor you know I'm talking
about and and and I was looking at
Twitter I think is this dude it's yeah
good okay I was looking at Twitter and
people were like upset that Anna Paquin
through this [ __ ] kills me the people
that said Anna Pat Anna Paquin only had
seven lines in the Irishman and them and
and people were like oh it's sexist and
it's like so hilarious first of all
because just make the [ __ ] movie you
want your Martin [ __ ] Scorsese well
what do you think martin scorsees gonna
make a movie about he's gonna make a
movie about some [ __ ] old gangsters
that's so he's gonna make a movie about
okay so people are like Oh Anna Paquin
was in an Eames you only had seven lines
first of all she auditioned for the part
you don't get Hollywood okay see ya the
gunk
yeah all right now also the movie is
literally about one of the main parts of
the movie is about a dad and a daughter
that don't have a good relationship and
don't speak to each other so how the
[ __ ] are you going to give her more
lines when that's what the movies about
people are so [ __ ] I wrote people mad
that Anna Paquin only had seven lines in
the irishman the movies about how De
Niro wasn't a good dad and didn't talk
with his daughter also had a pack was
still killed it and I was thinking about
how Anna Paquin was killing it
her performance was true acting just not
with the lines dude and you know that's
hard to do - it's so late
like there's not enough [ __ ]
everything they reboot is with women
anyway dude right now it's like
Ghostbusters and [ __ ] and then they made
Charlie's Angels which is uh you know
[ __ ] women and and it [ __ ] bombed
I can tell when the movies gonna bomb
dude I can't wait til that cats movie
comes out bro I can't wait til that cats
movie comes out that [ __ ] casting of
the cats movie is the most atrocious
casting of all time dude it's hilarious
and by the way good [ __ ] actors in
that movie just the way it's cast and
how put together it is bro it's such a
jason was in it imagine he's in it just
like that [ __ ] song
boo boo boo wiggle wiggle with it boo
boo and he just goes meow wiggle wiggle
wiggle
[ __ ] oh a girl comes with that big
fat cat butt meow boo boo boo boo dude
[ __ ] Jason
how much I don't know if this is true or
not but if JIT but Jason Derulo's whole
life is a sprite commercial I don't give
a [ __ ] do it I could just imagine him
just going like the fact that Jason
Derulo isn't a sprite you know he's in a
spike of Mahjong give a [ __ ] he's got to
be in a sprite Khmers if he's not in
sprite commercial he's in the sprite
commercial he I've never seen someone
who would more be in a [ __ ] sprite
commercial than Jason Derulo like not in
the coke commercial you know but like
well okay they want me to do sprite sure
wiggle wiggle with it bro how you make a
song about a big fat butt Beatles
Beatles are rolling over in the group
Beatles songs [ __ ] suck to you though
you know Beatles songs [ __ ] they're
just like we live in a yellow submarine
all right dude [ __ ] people love the
Beatles bro and they're just like Lucy
in the Sky with Diamonds and people are
like oh but it's about LSD oh really
oh yeah okay John Lennon is the [ __ ]
though that imagine song I mean it's a
disrespectful but John Lennon is the
[ __ ] I remember when I was a kid I saw a
[ __ ] movie called backbeat about the
Beatles with my parents and Ringo was
only in like two scenes and after the
[ __ ] movie I said to my dad I said
hey imagine you were in you you you were
an actor and you got the part of Ringo
and you're like hey guys I'm gonna be in
a movie about the Beatles and I play
Ringo people would be like so [ __ ]
like excited and then you're only in two
scenes and then my dad laughed and it
made me feel so [ __ ] good and because
I love to make my parents laugh all the
time and that's probably why I'm a
comedian so here we go
ads tipsy elves it's officially the
holidays and no party is complete
without getting your ultra festive
holiday clothing from tipsy house tipsy
elves is the one-stop shop for all your
holiday clothing needs they sell
one-of-a-kind Christmas sweaters dresses
family pajamas and onesies that will
transform your holiday party into an
unforgettable experience you will be the
life of the party reveal your hilarious
holiday alter-ego and score bragging
rights for having the best Christmas
sweater at the party
they have hilarious designs tipsy elves
hilarious sweaters we'll have everyone
at the party laughing a high-quality
comfortable interactive sweater skip the
small talk and bring the fun to the
party for drinking game sweaters to
tacky
tinsel and lights from drinking games
sweaters too tacky tinsel and lights got
it these sweaters are ultimate
icebreakers
they've got onesies they've got matching
pajamas for you and your loved ones
t-shirts Christmas suits dude Lite
elephant gifts they did all there's your
topic for you just go on the website and
check it out
say snow thank you too boring this year
try one of the hilariously awesome
designs from tipsy elves go to tipsy
elves dot-com / Congrats now to get 20%
off your entire order that's tipsy elves
calm / congrats for 20% off today don't
you understand that Stan's
do you remember what socks used to be
one of the worst things you can get at
Christmas I do do it when I was a kid I
hated getting socks now the whole game
changed and the whole game changed
because of this company Stan's okay he
used to go fruitcake then socks then
maybe a gift certificate to a restaurant
that you didn't like alright I remember
one time my aunt my aunt my ex and
actually she ended up divorcing but she
got me these Mickey Mouse hats and I was
like oh good idea and it took a picture
with my brother with the Hat and my mom
made me do it to send it to her those
those gifts sucks dude anyway times have
changed because over the last few years
Stan's has completely changed the
reputation of socks that's awesome dude
they took this piece of apparel no one
cared about and made them something
people can stop thinking about and now I
think about all the time I'm more in
stance right now and matter of fact I'm
wearing two of them right now
incredible design and comfort unmatched
durability casual everyday styles and
like no shows and cruise or performance
athletic products / they got all my
listeners get a free pair of socks with
their next order all you have to do is
go to Stan's comm / Congrats that Stan's
calm / Congrats I can't think of a
better gift
to give for this holiday then Stan's
sucks and that's the truth take the
guesswork out of the holiday shopping
stance makes gifts easy and everyone
will be happy
Stan's calm / congrats for all your
holiday needs and free socks with
purchase wiggle-wiggle-wiggle
jason Derulo's and cats bro you
understand what I'm saying
let's look up this [ __ ] cats the movie
first of all don't make cats the movie
and let me tell you why because cats the
musical [ __ ] sucks
that's why oh really [ __ ] Perry go
hack what is the [ __ ] thing Perrigo
hats
what the [ __ ] today's Jellicle Jellicle
cats oh yeah see ya
oh really Jellicle cats see ya oh are
you on [ __ ] Lucy in the Sky with
Diamonds when you wrote this see ya dude
Jellicle cats you understand what I'm
saying and Jason Derulo was like yup are
you [ __ ] out of your mind world Jason
Derulo said Jellicle cats sign me up
hey dude that whole thing is [ __ ]
utter nonsense imagine going to see a
matinee of cats good stay in the car if
you [ __ ] drive to cats for a matinee
stay in the parking lot in the car and
just make [ __ ] up in your head it'll be
way [ __ ] better dude I would never see
that movie [ __ ] cats dude they try to
make it all like [ __ ] woo cats and
then [ __ ] what's-her-name
just like on the [ __ ] with her
[ __ ] human nails and [ __ ] what's your
[ __ ] name taylor swift bro you know
focus on getting your catalog back focus
on getting your catalog back don't make
a movie what are you doing taylor swift
focus on getting you
Cadillac back from Scooter Braun Scooter
Braun how Scooter Braun not in the 1940s
hey what's up how you doing I'd like the
manager my name is scooter scooter Braun
hey how are ya he is a [ __ ] hat he'd
have a hat with like one of those
[ __ ] feathers in it hey how you doing
kiddo yeah you look really talented how
old are you one at the poopy well you're
gonna grow up to be a superstar
I'm scoot it's good Ron would you like
to go see a matinee what is it it's a
bunch of [ __ ] cats running around
it's [ __ ] absolutely ridiculous you'd
rather stay in a car come on let's go
get you some popcorn and Olli pops let's
go you're gonna be a big star one day
when in 90 years because that's when
you'll grow up you're so young you're
negative [ __ ] 40 did you come how it
just walks up to a pregnant lady
hello well I can tell you some gonna be
a big star what hey Peyton all right
yeah yeah sons Got Talent I don't even
if it's a boy or a girl yet I shut the
[ __ ] up you stupid [ __ ] let's go I'm
scooter on uh yeah dude wow I can't wait
to see cats I would never see cats do it
I would never see cats dude of oh the
people that are in it are suck air I've
never been a more s set of course
[ __ ] cast in my life I cannot [ __ ]
believe the people in counts let's just
roll down the people in cats okay Taylor
Swift Taylor Swift is playing bumble
arena see ya
the name see ya dude the names I dude
okay let me tell you some of course if
Hollywood asked me to be in cats I would
be in [ __ ] cats do you know why
because I want to be in cats
however right under that if my agent if
my manager Josh Lieberman called me an
it was like okay look there's weren't
cat I was wearing cats okay first of all
the way josh says cats it's definitely
spelled ki TZ right cat I mean cats all
right Judy all right kind of swift
vehicle like they have to put in there
and they want you
plant it's like stay up comedian cat you
know he was like I understand it jump is
the part is [ __ ] rum tum te dum
you know the Rose Room something to like
Thomas I'm page 75 looking it one go ham
but okay anyway and and I would be in it
but dude I would I would be like hey
Josh
Karl Hollywood back not being in cats
but I would be in cats anyway Taylor
Swift is bumble Erina SIA LSD Jennifer
Hudson is in it a leg of court you could
guess this cast and she plays Grizabella
hey just call these [ __ ] cats ELISA
and [ __ ] James Corden plays [ __ ] what
is the name here it won't it won't show
bustopher a transformer what's the name
bustopher jones dude dude that is such a
[ __ ] song that would be buy what's
that what's that group what's that as
adam duritz what's that group crown and
crows would make a song called Buster
for Jones dude
oh yeah but what's that [ __ ] long
December yeah that's what I saw he would
be like [ __ ] what's the one more night
in Hollywood where you met bustopher
jones that's mister that's [ __ ]
bustopher jones and it's called outside
um II just Elba's in it that's the only
one to me that is like doesn't make much
sense in this movie Macca vide of okay
the next two are the s so much people
that would be in the movie cats they
would literally like a real talking cat
would get over they would be like well
it's between you and a real
can cat and be like an you got it
because of course you're gonna be in
this [ __ ] movie because it's you okay
a real talking cat would be like but I'm
a real talking cat and they'd be like
sorry gotta give it to Judi Dench dude
Judi Dench's in cats
course and Ian McKellen rebel Wilson
course and then [ __ ] I'm sorry but
the one that makes the most sense is
Jason Derulo yeah it's just so funny to
me that goddamn Jason Derulo's and the
movie cats that I'm gonna rip my [ __ ]
dick off I mean dude Jason Derulo
imagine Jason Duke I cannot wait to look
up [ __ ] red carpet pictures of Jason
Derulo at the movie at the [ __ ] cats
premiere I cannot [ __ ] wait to see
the for real horseshit he's wearing dude
and I'd be like what are you doing
what I'm just wiggling with it dude and
like it wants it come out dude I've
talked about cats in this [ __ ] thing
it comes out soon right it's a good -
for sure Christmas movie well is this
movie for kids dude it's so creepy if I
was a kid this is how I'd be like when
my mom said hey you want to go see cats
I go like this know what it's for kids I
go like this
now why - Kelly - Kelly you don't want
to go in no I'll stay in the car you go
see it it's too caring I'll stay in this
stroller you guarantee always to carry
but Jason Derulo's in it
that's [ __ ] antic Nicholas but Judi
Dench is in it course she is James
Corden plays bustopher jones that's
that's a that's Counting Crows song
Jennifer Hudson's in it does she
preggers are about that makes sense
Taylor Swift is in it ballerina curse
and they're gonna go to see stupid jela
Kirk has negotiated Jellicle cat you
made me go see the musical I hate that
[ __ ] Despero that's right in for that
was rodent
the people who rode hours under LSD and
in 1980s they poop it okay here we go
now alright yeah shipstation when you're
selling online getting your orders out
can be a real pain especially during the
holiday rush choosing who to ship with
is time-consuming expensive so many
carriers to shoot to choose from how do
you know you're making the best choice I
use shipstation
for all my merch and everyone's happy
with that life rips and making no dents
people tweet me how fast I got their
merch two days later or even even
sometimes one day later if you sell
something if you selling something you
need this okay shipstation
I'm making the choice for you okay I'm
telling you babies whether you're
selling on your own website or on Amazon
Etsy or eBay shipstation will make it
left so much easier by bringing all
these orders together and finding the
best way to ship it alright it's
cost-effective it's awesome babies I've
saved so much time and money by using
ship station and now you will to take
the hassle out of holiday shipping this
year right now my listeners get to try
ship station for free for 60 days when
you use offer code Congrats see for
yourself why ship station is rated
number one by online sellers just visit
ship station calm click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in congrats that's ship station
calm then enter offer code congrats ship
station calm make ship happen that's it
just this in this congratulations is
brought to you by cash app the official
app of the log cabin let's look at the
cats trailer dude I know we've seen it
but we got to see it again do it wiggle
wiggle with me meow meow meow meow cats
movie no I rather stay in the car and
poop my pants and just have should have
died for 40 hours but no buts [ __ ] say
how fun
but it's a universal pick they make good
movies but this one's a weird one
[Music]
I'm sorry dude the cat's got a [ __ ]
top hat I'm out okay I mean talk about
Jellicle what talk about Jellicle III
cannot [ __ ] believe that jason
Derulo's in this movie dude I swear to
God at the end of this movie the cat
goes meow and you go what's that in your
cat pocket and pulls out a sprite and he
goes good wiggle wiggle with it
so beautiful
[Music]
Wow there's a [ __ ] thing in the back
it says milk bar mac is your [ __ ]
human cat little there little for a new
life that's me
twirling cats in a room that's so ornate
they've got ears that are on top of
their heads but also somehow it's not
uncomfortable
then no wear hats
James Corden of course and judi dench of
course and also of course Jason Derulo
drinking spray he dress Elba for some
reason Jennifer Hudson remember her
Ian McKellen is indeed naturally Taylor
Swift vehicle and rebel Wilson does
stuff like falls down and stuff
does this say inter doesn't have the
nerve to say introducing someone no no
no no that's a joke right
that didn't say that did it it's
introducing some it's introducing an
actor bro I haven't seen that in years
dude haven't seen that since like a
[ __ ] Sundance movie and when Sundance
first came and introducing Edie burns
dude and this [ __ ] goddamn movie cats
is get the nerve oh my god dude
introducing Francesca Hayward dude I'm
sorry I left so hard on my [ __ ] throw
up and I'm not even joking bro
introducing Francesca Hayward and then
it shows her mostly a cat just say
introducing another cat that's like
[ __ ] that's like when they do Johnny
Depp in Rango and you're like he's just
it's a cartoon lizard you [ __ ]
[ __ ] Johnny Depp's not in it that's
a lizard with a suitcase a dude that
drives me nuts when they do that when
it's like it's a cartoon and they're
like [ __ ] dude Oh for [ __ ] sake man
and introducing Oh
actually never mind it's a [ __ ] cat
[Music]
director of lemon is robbing the king
speech draw that movie woman ramp went
[ __ ] what's-his-name Colin Firth when
he's just like dude that movie ripped
when that guy didn't win the Oscar for
that bro he won the Oscar for that
close-up when he was like I wrote that
[ __ ] bro if I was in that movie oh [ __ ]
I would have killed that [ __ ] reading
the thing iiiiii bro that movie ripped
this directors good as [ __ ] shut up
you're [ __ ] in sell butters look at
this look at this what it just said I
don't even know and from Andy blank and
booba they're making up the bro bro
what's happening dude and from Andy
Blanken Bueller choreograph
choreographer of Hamilton [ __ ] dude
you made that [ __ ] up
you made that name up dude you know what
you made it up because the names of the
cats are so [ __ ] wacky that we're
like yeah they're like it's it's Andy
blank
it's Andy blank and they're like it's
it's gonna look weird in the credits
make it a different thing and some guy
was just like Andy blank and Bueller and
they're like yeah it looks like weird
dude it looks like weird [ __ ] James
Corden is playing bus stop McHenry James
James Henry is playing bus stop makuta
kulli dude the [ __ ] late-night host
is playing bus stop Jones we got a
[ __ ] it can't be any blank Andrew
Lloyd Webber and TS Eliot
[Music]
Wow eager Salva
or they have hats on what look at that
that's the best that line the next line
that cut it but the next the next the
next line they cut it but the next line
is a [ __ ] course I'm a [ __ ] I'm a
small car I'm a cap of a [ __ ] hat on
[ __ ] that was the next line they cut it
for the pigeon look at this how much
[ __ ] a song [ __ ] [ __ ] Jason Derulo
want you our trailers always go quiet
right before they end it'll be like and
then it'll go
[Music]
kept cats this holiday season you'll
believe bro [ __ ] uh göran bros Gorin
bros [ __ ] sent me some hats the bro
send me a deagle these [ __ ] guys sent
me a like a cap a cap bro butters what
the [ __ ] was that butters just when my
butters come here come here
are you okay come here buddy good boy
good boy doing what I say always good
boy just [ __ ] man
anyway anyway they sent me a [ __ ]
baseball hat and it has a [ __ ] wiener
dog on it and I wouldn't want to [ __ ]
deagle a whole episode you understand me
I would want to [ __ ] Charlie
goodnight the whole episode my scooter
broad pressure wouldn't even been better
hey how's it going I'm Scooter Braun
your kids a superstar what are you
talking about my kid I made yeah but
you're gonna grow up and you're gonna
get pregnant and then you're gonna have
a kid I can tell he's a superstar
already what's he gonna do I'm gonna
boss drums on him on he's to make up a
give him [ __ ] two sticks in a [ __ ]
pan [ __ ] gonna stand
I'm screwed Braun um every time I
[ __ ] talk about somebody day I get in
trouble dead [ __ ] right back like oh
yeah we heard about the [ __ ] Gorham
bros scooter Braun's gonna [ __ ] to
eat me now hmm dude I'm sorry but cats
bro oh wow they talked about it on h3
the cat's movie trailers a nightmare
they say you know what's weird is
sometimes they don't have the what do
you call it the the the
CGI'd all done until the movie like they
won't have it done on the trailer and
they will have it done in the movie so
maybe that's what's up but Universal
Pictures you know they come somebody
wrote on the comments under it this is
what the people in the bird box saw
before they died that's hilarious
memories nothing more than memories you
know we got some memories
we've got memories were saying
well how many memories would you like to
purchase memories are about 950 but if
you get to we'll give you a [ __ ] deal
[Applause]
[Music]
three four - man 3 you can buy a dozen
and we'll charge you for dead [ __ ]
memories what if in the middle of cats
it went off the rails and that's the
song that happened you understand how
[ __ ] that will be my favorite movie
do you understand you don't do it you
[ __ ] don't and they'll just keep
making the same [ __ ] [ __ ] grow some
[ __ ] balls and [ __ ] bastardize
some [ __ ] man I'll never be in another
movie again after this [ __ ] up I
guess but you know maybe Netflix Netflix
[ __ ] seems to employ a boy and I told
him to [ __ ] write more shirts off
scenes in him in it and they were like
you got it and they send me the signs
and I'm ripping through the [ __ ]
jungle with my shirts off
dude I just want to be in a movie where
I'm just like I'm so young dude but uh
yeah so I was gonna talk about that and
I was going to talk about what is up
dude with what and I gotta say like I
don't know much about politics I really
don't I don't know much about politics I
don't but and I you know I don't like to
talk about mm-hmm I don't like to talk
about how you know Trump is just a
[ __ ] lunatic you know he is naturally
I don't talk about it that much because
I just I stay out of politics this is
not political okay what the [ __ ] is Joe
Biden ever saying okay what is he saying
I mean my dad is his age and my dad has
never said anything about let me just go
to this clip sure I saw that made me
aware when I was in law school proudly
for Holloway okay probably for your dad
first african-american state senator in
the state of in the state of Delaware
everything about there we go okay good
good good nice class Oh see when off the
teleprompter went off the [ __ ] that was
designed what he was going to say all of
his handlers right now we're going like
this right now in the back of course to
stick to the plan wasn't okay but when
he says by the way when Joe Biden says
by the way more like it's like that's
like when superimposed when he says by
the way [ __ ] the planes flying into
the [ __ ] Twin Towers like that's what
it is
superimposed polling just going down and
down and down by the what by though you
know first African American we love
everybody and this and that by the way
by the way okay and by the way you know
I should understand and to get hot I got
I got hairy legs what you said that
where the [ __ ] is this going now when
somebody says something as wacky as [ __ ]
as that when you're talking politics and
when you're running for president okay
and you just die vert all right you just
show up to the pool party with a speedo
on right and everyone's like whoa what's
going on
you better have something in store like
it's a [ __ ] the end of an M night
Shyamalan movie okay you better be this
guy you better have the deck stacked but
Joe Biden is just jumping out of the
plane with Skittles and then people are
like why you got those skittles he's
like well cuz you can eat them on the
way down and you're like but you're
gonna die one and then you open up your
chute and he's just like but his last
taste and you're like that guy didn't
think it out did he you're jumping out
of a plane with a [ __ ] pocket full of
Skittles you [ __ ] okay let me just go
back first of all he knows he's [ __ ]
up already but he's into it and he's
like I could do it it's an ego thing
because he's got he's stuttering she's
like I uh
he's already knows he shouldn't say the
hairy legs thing but but it's like I'm
Joe Biden I made it this far
hairy legs that turn that that turned
blonde in the Sun is this a [ __ ]
Daniel Bedingfield song I got I got I
got I got I got hairy legs that turn
that turn about blonde in the Sun and
the kids used to come up and reach in
the pool and rub my leg down
so it was trained and then watch the
hair come back up again okay they look
at it so I learned about roaches I
learned about kids jumping on my lap and
I've loved kids jumping on my lap and I
tell you what the men they're now all
men the guys that work with down here
and they're all guys at the time they're
all good men most of them made a loft
lot of themselves and Earl Larkin had a
rough time in some of you knew Earl I'd
if I came back as a public defender what
you just said is one of the most
insanely idiotic things I have ever
heard this [ __ ] thing from what do
you call it what is it from some 7lu
Billy Madison God I mean just wow just
wow I got hairy legs and I used to be in
a pool and I used to be in a pool and I
would and I would have kids and the kids
would would be in a pool and they would
they would rub my legs down and to
straight to straighten the hair and then
they would let that let it go and they
would and they would watch it and the
hair would just curl up okay
so I know about roaches ah a lot so and
I love having kids on my lap but you're
running for president so you can't say
that stuff the thing is though no the
thing is though you're jumping out of an
airplane with a pocket full of Skittles
then you're jumping out of a plane with
a pack
full of them skin off just like that
[ __ ] Alanis Morissette song dude
Jason Derulo as in cats [ __ ] dude
that song wiggle wiggle wiggle
oh my god it's hilarious
he's got to be in a sprite commercial
dude jason Derulo's in a sprite I don't
give a [ __ ] I'm looking Derulo sprite
100% jason Derulo's oh he's not OK
I'm pissed he is though we all know that
deep down we all know that he's in a
sprite commercial deep down did he get
the coke commercial did get the coke
commercial oh he's in a [ __ ] no no
he's not a coke commercial the coca-cola
anthem for 2018 he performs colors the
coca-cola anthem but he wasn't in a coke
commercial okay I mean technically maybe
it is a coke commercial
dude Jason Derulo man it's a handsome
[ __ ] though huh how much has he
had sex with [ __ ] four different
women and that's it
he's just like well you know I like to
treat them you know and girls are just
like can you just oh my god this song do
it wiggle these are the lyrics go up all
the way hey dude I love when rapper a Oh
Jason say something to a highlighter I
got one question how do you fit it all
in them jeans you know what to do with
that big fat butt wiggle wiggle wiggle
what's what's better this or [ __ ]
cats for real like by TS Eliot I bet TS
Eliot would be like uh-huh
your booty like two planets ah juvenile
I mean that's like some [ __ ] hey what do
you think of it what do you think you
need a new teacher she got booty and I
lost like two planets
she got booted he looks like two planets
really yeah it looks like she got Mars
on the left and and Pluto on the right
she got two planets in her jeans and I
put my face on it what does it eat it
eat it love it hate it up okay well yeah
bro
damn dude okay I [ __ ] it's good we're
good we did it Wow
that flew by you know what to do with
that big fat butt so dick suck
controlling yeah I imagine you said that
to your wife you know what to do with
your big fat butt right you know what to
do with it right what wiggle it excuse
me I don't know when I when I used to
being pools I used to be in pools and
kids would come up and they'd be under
the water and I would hold them there
and they would they would they would
show they would they would they would
put their hands down my legs and this is
the thing about this is not sexual and
the interesting thing too is I've been
accused also of like doing things like
whispering sweet nothings into
eleven-year-old in their ears but right
now this is nothing to do with that this
is the kids I'll hold him underwater
they they put they rub my legs and at
the end and and the hair goes straight
and then they let the the leg they they
let their hands go out they take them
off my legs and that's the part of like
the least right because I like their
hands on my legs but they release them
and then the hair curls up like a like
in a wreck like a boat like a so the it
curls up
like a boner like like what you'd get if
you saw if you were just like saw
somebody that you were attracted to but
I'm not trying to kid so the things that
the hair will just curl up right like a
clitoris if you know and and it will
curl up and and so I know about roaches
I got question dude quick question
[Laughter]
yeah I'll take questions from there you
go there's a reporter right there I know
you haven't seen you for a long time
what's your question
oh yes Mr Bond I just have one question
about the the what you just said there
um looks at his notes
butters if you growl butters don't growl
butters you're an in cell dude we're
going off on that man butter isn't
[ __ ] butters come here butters come
here come here butters come on attaboy
okay good
well you guys here we go that's it
download the download the cash app for
free on the App Store or Google Play
market text me eight one eight two three
nine 7087 every now and then I go in I
check my text and you guys what's up and
a taxi guys I took two guys video as a
text guys stuff like that
and all that [ __ ] by merch at Crystal
historic chris chris d'elia calm and
that's the [ __ ] and Peoria Peoria Chacon
Chicago Marilia I'm coming over Ilya
Chicago Irvine Pasadena West Palm Beach
Las Vegas Nevada
go get your tickets now and my Netflix
specials coming out in a few months so
that's what's up you guys have a good
have a good have a good day and remember
you know I used to sit I would be in a
pool and
and with whole kids underwater mob I see
have a good one
[Music]